all right richard take take your jersey  now and share it take that thing and cut  it up i'm so sorry oh [ __ ] i hate this  howard  come on jizz  [Music]  that thing's really boy through that  jersey  oh my god oh i hate this jd you [ __ ]  dude i didn't do it you started it well  you could have stopped keep cutting keep  cutting less you know less talking more  cuttings  oh wow  jesus oh wow this thing cuts right  through it this thing doesn't [ __ ]  around don't cut yourself i hate this  hour  i hate this keep going keep going  richard wears that all the time too to  every meeting  every fantasy football draft a lot of  memories on that shirt huh oh my god  there's so many beer stains and i know  exactly what game the beer stain is from  it's in tatters now howard this is  horrible wow  wow that piece is too big  richard was going to sew that back  together like frankenstein's monster  exactly  you